[Music]
hey there friends so i'm wrestling with
a particular conundrum today one that
has definitely got me a little bit of my
feels that i want to share with you all
namely the gap between what we want to
see happen and what we're capable of
making happen tricks here from
drexfactor poi sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow arts to benefit
your body and brain and uh today we're
gonna get into that brain side of things
a little bit but before we dive in i
just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les machinski and
becca beckham thank you all so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission
all right so i have a mission for the
day and it involves
going down to the local dance studio so
come walk with me while explaining
what's going on so context um i've been
working on a poi dance piece for like
really the last two and a half months
there's an idea that came to me
about midway through june
that i wanted to see if i could capture
with
playing around with movements
and i started working on it
and it has become
kind of a glaring reminder to me that
sometimes the
gap between my ambitions and my
abilities
is a lot greater than i wish it were so
like i imagine that it will surprise
nobody to discover that like
one of the big goals for me as an artist
for the past few years
has been to incorporate more dance and
storytelling into my work um
you know i do those monthly flow videos
i have been uh doing a series talking
about like the structure of how we look
at poi dance and performance
and like
you know that
that is a thing that has been an open
and active
project for me for a while now
and i can see in my head the thing that
i want this to be i can see in my head
what i think we're capable of but taking
it out of my head and actually making it
a physical and real thing
that is quite challenging not the least
of which because my own abilities as a
dancer are quite limited i got into it
pretty late in life
and it's six feet tall
i'm kind of
above the size that usually that works
out for so honestly how i started this
process off is i was just
walking around one day kind of deep in
my feels about something that happened
back in june
and i saw something in my mind's eye i
saw a really brief movement phrase and i
immediately
like
pulled out my poi and set this down and
got it on video before i could forget it
as luck would have it i got this bit of
inspiration while i was listening to a
particular song
and the song was really great at
channeling the emotions that i was
feeling in that moment
so between this kind of seed of a phrase
as well as you know having this music to
work with you know those are two very
very important things to start off a
performance piece with and so what i
began doing was putting on that piece of
music regularly as i was flowing out and
just experimenting with where it took me
kind of playing around with different
qualities of movement with different
movement styles and seeing what's stuck
see what felt like it worked with the
kind of vibe that i was trying to get
across
and also trying to get to the core of
what it was i was trying to say with all
of this so i've now taken several hours
worth of footage and edited it down to
what i think were some of the highlights
and the things that really nailed the
feeling that i was going for in there
and i've now been working on trying to
distill all of that down into
a specific
set of choreography that i can then do
to hopefully shoot a video of in the
near future and like this process has
been really hard like
painfully hard
part of that of course is just taking
something that you experienced in the
moment and trying to make it repeatable
as choreography is really really hard
because sometimes that individual phrase
of movement is the result of just
these three unique pieces of momentum
that were happening in the moment kind
of just like falling together
and other times you know you look at
this thing that you're trying to
accomplish you just think oh my god what
stays what goes how do i actually
assemble these into an order that gets
across what i wanted to get across which
like i think this is a thing that pretty
much any artist struggles with at some
point they're really looking at trying
to get across the ideas impressions and
emotions that are at the core of their
work
and
it's never
kind of turns out to be 100 of what we
want it to be does it now and it doesn't
help that i'm really working backwards
from the way that i normally do things
wherein i will start by writing
choreography and then usually somewhere
along the process while the choreography
is being assembled i'll be looking at
video of myself performing it and think
oh all of these pieces are coalescing
around this particular idea i think
that's what this piece is about whereas
in this case i'm starting with the idea
and then trying to write the
choreography around it which is just so
much freaking harder for me and if i can
be real with you it's kind of like
depressing
humbling
because one of those things that i'm
discovering in the course of this is
just like how limited i still am as a
choreographer my capacity to do the same
thing over and over again and hit
specific counts because of course this
all started off as flow i wasn't trying
to hit any counts in the course of it so
going from one thing to the other is
like really really brutal sometimes and
of course as i'm going back to these
highlight reels i'm looking at myself
and being like
dang this was really the best that i had
to offer there's a lot of days when i've
honestly just kind of been dreading
working through this process you know
going through the old footage and trying
to pull out whatever nuggets there
happened to be that i think are good
versus trying to assemble it all into a
final form and it
just feels like i'm throwing spaghetti
at the ball half the time oh so i will
be real with you it is super noisy on
this road so yeah i mean this is a thing
that i wrestle with in general sometimes
is just like seeing in my head
the capabilities of what things can be
and then physically doing them myself
and just kind of being disappointed in
the gap between those things
i feel like it's sometimes easier when i
don't have an expectation coming into
something when i don't have a vision
but
i do this time and
yeah navigating that uh
navigating that gap can be kind of
disheartening but here i am at the dance
studio i have it reserved for the next
hour
i have at least in theory a plan of what
i want to accomplish in that hour
so let's see how it goes
[Music]
oh
okay well today went better than
expected um i don't have the entire song
choreographed but i'm probably like
two-thirds of the way ish through it
um
there are some things that clicked for
me today that hadn't before and some
stuff that's falling into place along
with the music and just yeah overall
looking back on the videos that i
recorded today i'm feeling not terrible
about it there's definitely some
connective tissue that needs to be put
in place but we're getting there step by
step
it does dawn on me that like part of the
reason this is so difficult is that i
don't choreograph in this fashion very
often
um i do write choreography and i do flow
but it's rare that i write choreography
that is specifically to music
and i can't help but think that like if
i actually
did that more often if i made that a
regular habit to say like
write something every week that was
choreographed to like 30 seconds to a
minute's worth of music that doing
things like this in the future might be
a little bit easier after all part of
what makes the thing difficult is a lack
of practice at it so maybe part of the
key to this is practicing the thing that
i have a hard time with right what a
concept of course part of this could
just be the endorphins of coming out an
hour straight of doing dance but i'm
choosing to be optimistic on this one
but i mean also too just on a kind of
existential level the struggle of trying
to bridge the gap between our ambitions
and our abilities i think is something
that we all work on for the entirety of
our life
one of those things that tends to happen
as you improve your craft is that you
reach ever further and higher up and you
push limits of what you can do
so maybe in the grand scheme of things
it's not a bad thing to have that gap be
there it can be very frustrating but at
the same time it's a sign that you're
growing right but as for right now i'm
pretty exhausted and i still need to
send out a bunch of emails today so i'm
gonna hit the road thank you all for
joining me today and uh please make sure
to like subscribe comment all of that
good stuff if you got anything out of
this video yeah
[Music]
this video would not have been possible
if it were not for the kind support of
all of these nice people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon and they along with the people
listed down in the description helped to
make this video and all the videos on my
channel possible thank you one and all
for your support if you out there
watching are not currently a member and
you'd like to become one you can do so
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if you
are watching on youtube there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards even better you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring poi spinning
and flow arts to the wider world so go
check that out please and thank you if
you dug this video i will leave a link
to a playlist of other vlogs like it
down in the description as well as up on
screen if you're watching on youtube
also uh the youtube algorithm thinks
that you'll like this top video based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a shot too
thank you so much for watching this
video and coming through with me in my
hour of despair and doubt and seeing me
through to the other side i will see you
all with a new video on wednesday
peace